но аресою горять автомобілі автомобілі
загроза роповсуження
кинджали калібри балістика і дрони 2
січня Росія випустила по Україні майже
100 ракет різних типів і 35 шахедів вони
атакували критичну інфраструктуру а
також промислові цивільні та військові
об'єкти унаслідок цього постраждало 130
людей п'ятеро
загинуло
цього разу росіяни трохи змінили тактику
обстрілів констатує керівник центру
військово-правових досліджень Олександр
Мусієнко якщо під час попередньої
масованої атаки 29 грудня під ударом
Була майже Вся Україна то цього разу
основними цілями стали Київ і
Харків ворог намагається діяти
концентрованіше тобто вони
зосереджуються на одній двох цілях в
даному разі це були два українських
міста Київ і Харків
і намагаються більшою кількісті засобів
повітряного нападу ракетами різних типів
Як крилатих
11х555 так і балістичних аеробалістичних
гіперзвукових кінджал
іскандерм
S300 намагаються пройти наші засоби
протиповітряної оборони тобто Росія
вирішила бити більшою кількістю ракет по
меншій кількості цілей тоді збивати їх
український ППО значно
складніше можливо ворог надалі якраз
буде змінювати підходи скажімо зменшуючи
кількість потенційних цілей і географію
ударів як це буває що фактично по всім
містам українським від півночі до півдня
від Сходу до заходу зараз вони будуть
під час атак концентруватись вибирати
одну- дві цілі і для того щоби більшою
кількістю ракет пробувати проходити е
захист ППО і таким чином вражати більше
цілей за пть днів починаючи від 29
грудня у комбінованих атаках війська РФ
випустили по території України майже 300
ракет і понад 200 шахедів ще жодна
держава не відбивала подібних ударів
наголосив президент України Володимир
Зеленський Це величезне навантаження для
протиповітряної оборони україни- каже
речник командування повітряних сил ЗСУ
Юрій
Ігнат масований обстріл і є на то що
масований
щоби не виснажити а навантажити
перевантажити нашу пепо спочатку дрони
потім скільки засобів і все в одну точку
одночасно Візьміть
Ізраїль Ізраїль який був атакований
хамас летіло усе це у нас і безпілотники
ударного типу балістика летіла там плюс
по балістичній тракторії летіли снаряди
рсзв Гради Як одиночні так і пакетами
крилаті раке там все летіло і все
одночасно і ізраїльська ППО найкраща у
світі мені так
видається не впоралась із повністю
відбиттям тому що Ну просто банально не
вистачає на таку кількість систем щоби
його відбити от ласне цей ворог теж має
на меті от не просто точково завдавати
ударів щоб відбитися від таких атак
Україна витрачає багато ракет і
боєприпасів- каже Юрій Ігнат А ще
російські загарбники постійно полюють на
україн системи ППО тому військові ЗСУ
змушені постійно маскуватися і
переміщатися щоб їх не виявили і не
поцілили ворожі засоби саме тому що йде
велика кількість ракетдронів доводиться
витрачати велику кількість
боєприпасів до зенітних гармад і ракет
зокрема ми повинні розуміти що ми
постійно витрачаємо ракети постійно
витрачаємо боєприпаси і нам потрібно
більше щоби Росія ну вони ж будуть
нарощувати відповідно на удари А нам
потрібно нарощувати запаси тих ракет
щоби їх відбивати військово-промисловий
комплекс РФ продовжує виготовляти ракети
незважаючи на санкції росіяни можуть
провести ще кілька таких масованих
комбінованих атак вже найближчим часом
не виключають експерти Для цього вони
накопичили чималу кількість засобів я не
виключаю що найближчим часом вони
повторять ще одну дві три ну такі атаки
в
сенсі в максимально стислі терміни
наскільки це їм дозволяють їхні умови
там поперезарядці по
підготовці і так далі а потім
зновутаки Ну як мені здається скажемо
так десь за цих три
місяці маючи інформацію про розрахункову
кількість ракет які є у ворога зараз
підготовлені я наголошую не виготовлені
а підготовлені до запуску це ну в такій
кількості як вони зараз це інтенсивно
атакують може вистачити до п'яти ударів
і скоріш за все вони будуть намагатися
це провести в якомога стисліше терміни
100 ракет різних типів на місяць вони
можуть виготовляти стосується тих ракети
які ми атакували сьогодні
зокрема От і не беремо до уваги ракети
с300 s400 це занітні ракети це вони їх
просто застосовують по
землітсоток в них є дуже багато але вони
можуть ними бити там кілометрів 50 70 до
100 і то коли 100 Це вже дуже неточно
вони летять
тому цих ракет кинджал типу х
повітряного базування калібр іскандери
обох
типів близько стану місяць Як озвучили
з точки зору затяжної війни з точки зору
економіки у Росії все непогано
незважаючи на санкції тож На жаль для
України російська Оборонна промисловість
процвітає Тому не варто очікувати що в
Росії закінчаться боєприпаси десь
найближчим часом експерти не розцінюють
такі атаки як помсту Україні за якісь
військові здобутки на кшталт знищення
корабля новочеркаськ вони вважають це
цілеспрямованим терором проти
українського населення ці атаки
демонструють що Росія не відмовляється
від тактики терору проти цивільного
населення від тактики руйнування
випаленої землі це удар психологічний це
фактор психологічного рору проти
цивільного населення Щоб у людей
формувалась думка що тепер так буде
завжди ну тобто ви розумієте
що Вони намагаються діяти Вони
намагаються посилити такий таку дещо
паніку розпач і плюс спричинити
руйнування особливо в критичній
інфраструктурі взагалі формулювання
помста і так далі це використовується
російською пропагандою виключно для
внутрішньої аудиторії У них є свої
стратегічні задуми відповідні вони
накопичували ракети не просто просто так
щоб здачі давати Так вони накопичували
вдарити і і робити те про що я щойно
казав завдавати ударів в інформаційному
і в військовому плані для того щоби
гнітити Україну змусити здатися і так
далі Ну і відповідно представлено це
буде все зрозуміло своїм глядачам як акт
возмездия помсти за корабель вони це
роблять щодня навіть не завдаючи таких
ударів Вони беруть просто збивають у
себе е в фейсбуках там чи в себе в
інформаційних ресурсах по п'ять літаків
наших на день хаймерсів пачками надані
союзниками системи Patriot nasams та
irсті продовжують рятувати сотні життів
система patriіot збиває не лише
балістичні цілі але і аеродинамічні цілі
але саме захист від балістики забезпечує
що доказано цієї ночі зокрема 10
кинжалів було знищено е Які хо летіли в
серце столиці скажемо так які б мали
якісь потенційні цілі там ось так
звичайно є руйнування є від уламків і
від незбитих ракет на Київщині Ну але
Подивіться скільки засобів повітряного
нападу було направлено 99 це лише ракет
ще 35 Дронів напередодні це величезна
кількість на Це все треба ракети і
засоби засоби і ракети які ми отримуємо
від Заходу Росія і надалі тероризуватиме
мирних україн щоб поширити панічні
настрої в суспільстві Україна потребує
більше систем ППО і снарядів до них щоб
дати відсіч РФ для цього необхідна
швидка реакція
[музика]
заходу це може підштовхнути Європейський
союз і Сполучені Штати щоб розблокувати
пакети проблема тут у тому що пакет який
зараз розглядає Євросоюз набагато менший
ніж спочатку було погоджено у США кажуть
що це останній пакет для України тож
навіть якщо Україна отримає цю допомогу
Питання в тому чи буде вона продовжувати
отримувати допомогу після цього І
наскільки цієї допомоги вистачить
Україні Україні також знадобляться
боєприпаси Україні знадобиться більше
зброї схоже Великобританія вирішила
відправити в Україну ракети ППО але це
не все що потрібно Україні і Питання в
тому чи може захід надавати Саме те що
потрібно Україні щоб протриматися довше
за
Росію
ми відбиваємося Бачите як це
відбувається але захід зокрема повинен
зрозуміти що перестати допомагати
Україні - це перестати допомагати собі
Україна маючи захистивши Європу таким
собі буфером стіною створивши
ешалоновану ППО зробить надійну систему
проти повітряної оборони захистить
захист від небажаних наслідків і так
далі
тому не допомагати Україні це вистрілити
бівного сьогодні це мають зрозуміти і на
в Сполучених Штатах і країни в Європі
які
сумніваються